bella tutti ragazzi venuti a questo
nuovo video io sono fuori j
e oggi siamo su motori dreams sui motori
dreams un videogame che mi avete
consigliato da secoli permette consiste
nell consiste in un arena un'arena di
vario genere dipende poi dalla rena che
sceglie e bisogna rimanere l'ultimo in
piedi diciamo tra tre avversari che
adesso vedremo
[Musica]
ok io sono il blu praticamente posso
soltanto spingere ceccarini non cadere
allora aspettate che vinco io ok
perfetto ultimo è poi gli altri cadono a
seguito è un gioco
se uno dei giochi più non sense che io
abbia mai giocato in tutta la vita
consiste nel procedimento a rimanere
proprio l'ultimo in piedi
però fanno morire le scene tipo quando
cadi e la roba assurda si può continuare
anche se la partita finisce tipo adesso
marrone è stato schiacciato da una
regola e niente proprio attivamente
tirare pugni tipo così a singoli oppure
spintoni a due mani oppure saltare come
uno spazi così niente cosa sta facendo
il verde robe oscene tipo è un ubriaco
ragazzi e per che aspettate che voglio
provare a tirare una spinta potente al
verde ok ok ok no schede da solo
perfetto il cambio ma paraga perché
avranno aspettate che prova di farlo
perché mi sembra troppo porta
ok in questa volta non lo sento by me lo
sento
vinco se date si no secondo la dai no
ultimo perfetto sempre è sempre uguale
ragazzi non cambia mai
ok haga cambio di mappa ce ne sono
diverse di mappe non c'è solo quello
ovviamente perché sennò non sarebbe poi
così divertente sarebbe troppo
ripetitivo mi accanisco subito sul
marrone stavolta oggi gli ho fatto fare
un volto della madonna ragazzi però
vedere se riesco anche a schiacciarlo
non ho mancato perfetto e poi tutti gli
altri ha seguito non mi schiacciare
bianco non mi spiace oddio oddio è
appena è successo qualcosa di fantastico
ragazzi ok ne prova un'altra ragazza ce
ne sono casinò quindi inutile rimanere
sempre sulla stessa
ok questo sembra normalissima rehn ha
quindi i babà do sul verde stavolta
perché prima che cazzo è successo ok
questa non me l'aspettavo mi è rimasta
una mano incastrata in una tegola non
riesco più alzarmi ok ok perfetto
sir ragazzi questo è il gioco veramente
pino sensi che abbia un po di dio che
calcio tirato al marrone o che l'aia ci
riprovo perché è stato fantastico
stavolta però non va di mezzo ci va a
qualcun altro tipo non sol verde forse
no verde verde verde
addio guardate la testa del verde
guardate il set
oddio ragazzi verde stato veramente
qualcosa di epico incastrato la testa
nella tegola oddio io sto facendo tipo
non lo so l'aquilone old io cos'è perché
sono a testa in giù ok forse becco il
bianco aspettate aspettate
noi di poco però è accaduto lo stesso
con un pezzo di ok mista stuprando no
son riuscito a liberarmi da invece cosa
fa
cos'è l'angelo che non sulla neve
ragazzi stesso gioco proprio non è
proprio il non sense è peggio di di di
tursi face of law wing e gravi thibon
messi insieme e proprio l'apoteosi del
nonsense cosa sta facendo il bianco ci
vado io sopra si ok nagano cambiato
mappa questa non l'ho mai fatto dio
sembra sembra notify zheng aver presente
tipo o qualcuno se li ricorda quelli che
usa vi per costruire la torre altissima
ok io sono l'unico in viola sopra anche
per crollare
mi butto tipo facendo una mossa di
pressing sul verde vediamo se riesco
dubito schienamento normalmente sono io
quella terra però non fa niente ok mi
sono alzato la torre sta veramente per
crollare anche senza che nessuno la
spinga marrone ce l'ha proprio con me ok
non chiedetevi che cosa sta facendo il
blu raga devo riavviare questa la
riavvio assolutamente perché voglio
provare a tuffarmi beccare qualcuno in
volo
ok ci vado subito sul sul bianco cos'è
cos'è due ragazzi due schede
mammamia schienamento multiplo ok il
bianco è andato proprio ok ragazzi e
fantastico sto gioco credetemi
prendetelo perché epico prova buttarmi
subito vedere se riesco sennò pazienza
vado vado vado se magari è caduto no non
ci sono riuscito ad avere quel quid ue
stanno i santi rando testate io ci
rinuncio cambia una pa ragazzi ok raga
vestae nuova ce ne sono un casino ce ne
sono tipo ma decine hanno contate prima
devo staccare ogni volta che è che
cambia mappa perché sono impossibile
perché ovviamente quando cambia mappa
deve uscire dal gioco e poi rientrare io
mi sono incastrato c'è il marrone che mi
sta saltando addosso perfetto sono
l'unico idiota rimasti incassato ok
beh fa vj da sfondo alla stampa
cosa sta succedendo ok ragazzi stavolta
subito la carica parto immediatamente
deciso vai su ok niente lega sono scarso
oltre oltre che a fare i movimenti di
break dance robe del genere sono scarso
che grazie il bianco me la ricordo
questa oppure a tu mi devi pure salire
addosso braca e gentile
mamma mia mamma mia che scene vietata ai
minori ok cambio questa mi ispirava al
nome ragazzi si chiama uncaged ma so che
cos'è ok sembra una torre insensata
ebbene dobbiamo usarlo giu oddio si
scassa tutto però non crolla niente ok
questa non mi piaceva grazie marrone
perché sono sempre più che non mi piace
voglio essere il bianco
ok grande c'è fa vige il demolitore
oddio sono svenuto perché mi è caduta la
pietra in testa va bene rai a questa non
aveva senso
ok ne provo una normale raga perché
ovviamente oltre alle mode ci sono anche
le arene normali
vediamo di fare
aiko downstairs non so che cos'è ma mi
piace entrare vaio si ok perché io devo
partire vicino alle scale che mi butta
giù subito stop presente lo sapevo
grazie
così si trattano è impazzito il verde
ragazzi
il verde è impazzito è andato fuori di
testa devo rifarla di farla perché non
voglio cadere ultima non è giusto ok ce
la faccio a me ne vado via subito così
non mi butti no c'è verso la grande
grande così grazie mille
ok ok grazie grazie grazie
oddio ok ok ragazzaccio l'ultimo perché
veramente sono troppe voi provatelo
comunque perché la figata mi butto
subito a così non mi butti giù
ok ok ok un paio di palle perché adesso
mi stanno arrivando tutti addosso prima
grazie a marrone mi vuole sempre bene va
bene raga è un gioco completamente
nonsenso provatelo perché una figata è
rimbalzato arrivo prima a io9 marrone mi
ha potuto va bene comunque dai se vi è
piaciuto il video
mettete mi piace grazie verde ti voglio
bene anch'io
niente se vi è piaciuto video mettete mi
piace se vi piace il contrasto del
bianco anche
niente mette il piace la pagina facebook
lasciato un commento e ci vediamo
prossimo video bella ragazzi